mais si jean louis murat deschamps en
ville pour un anti portrait chinois
débrider un jean louis murat bonsoir
bonsoir
tu as commencé par des petits boulots
tête et coiffes plagistes bord du man
barma remet le disque quand été à
saint-tropez têtu voyez avec le showbiz
il faisait quoi quand tu leur servez là
ça m'excite un peu et ça me débecte
hervouet de servir
barclays quand on met ça
non mais non enfin un impact est là
enfin maintenant que tu fais des disques
il les trouve toujours aussi sale au
parfum utiliser encore plus ou moins ce
sera encore plus si ses portes est monté
à paris une première fois ce qui est
très drôle d'ailleurs ton histoire cia
clermont ferrand du monde à paris
descend et clermont remonte à paris à la
première fois que tu es monté c'était là
où tu as rencontré les gens drm c'est
ton à payer quand même
bassil pharand la bande oui et puis
après tu as fait un groupe terre
descendu la borne du tennis est un peu
compliqué pour moi donc pas redescendue
épitaphe un groupe qui s'appelle clara
et puis un jour tu as vu débarquer vers
william sheller jean bernard et c'était
pas mal c'était sympa un grosse surprise
pour moi
ouais c'est encourager les gens bernard
qui était que le fan de la première
heure qui m'a suivi péta des fans comme
ça ouais moi s'il ya des gens qui sont
des fanatiques de débuts il ya plus en
plus qui devraient être assurés et
qu'elle rapporte a fait une chanson qui
s'appelait suicidez vous le peuple est
mort c'est satan et le système soit
c'est un scandale national
bah oui parce que
enfin sa porte pas sourire évidemment
mais enfin c'est l'ia c'est l'époque du
suicide mode d'emploi aussi chez morrow
et kelly l'indicé maman suicidé ce qui
se soit suicidé pour autre chose que ce
qu'en suisse il pupone chansons mais
enfin ça a servi de prétexte et pour moi
ça a été une rupture quand j'étais un
peu mot dire ils ont été de te passer à
la radio a tout à fait je l'église
tandis que pathé a tout arrêté
c'était michael abraham ouais alors hop
ou qui pousse au cul avec le suicide
ils ont été obligés d'arrêter les
gouttes beau ouais ouais va chauffer
pour ne pas déprimer là
pas dit des trucs terribles attentats
des primes tu dis si tu t'étais enlever
tous les poils tu disais c'est quoi
cette histoire s'est passée ont été
enlevés tous les poils c'est
pourquoi j'étais malheureux c'était
malheureux voulait sauter par la fenêtre
puis 7 sur 10
[Musique]
c'était gramat lot
tu te défoncer c'était suite à des
histoires de défense c'était un mélange
de déception amoureuse
surtout c'était surtout ma propre
déception
tu savais que j'allais y arriver mais ça
arrive et pas moi ça c'est terrible que
relater nouveau a clairement fait or tu
viens à paris pour la promo à l'hôtel
oui et tu vis comment est clair moi je
suis un bon marin tpm ouais ouais
spartiate
ouais un peu ce club de bonheur ouais je
crois va il fait du sport je fais des
chansons d'abord c'est comment d'être là
bas
seul fait ni chaud ni froid en fait
j'habite clairement jeu pour habiter
ailleurs
ouais je joue souvent j'habite chez moi
je sais pas où ça va rien dire ça va un
peu tout dit avec
clermont ferrand signifie qu aucun
charme ce charme que j'ai trouv c'est
que c'est chez moi mais tu te défonces
pas du tout non tu crois il avait gagné
un moment c'est pourquoi s'en prendre à
bord et pourquoi
c'est pas c'est devenu mon ami il ya un
quart d'heure gens cherchent un port ça
se trouve ça non ouais mais j'avais pour
mais dans ces pôles plus dur à trouver
ça te fait quoi je dis bien ouais hein
et des effets secondaires cody coded un
peu en latin signé avec leurs jeans pour
six albums c'est tranquille là pendant
trente ans maintenant un bon pote
enfants chez fameux sera quitte pour six
ans ouais et encore qui sait ils peuvent
te virer dessus et toi tu peux pas
partir non j'en ai pas envie d'un apport
au vide sans gentil avec toi c'était
l'impression d'un an que ça y est on a
trouvé un autre chez toi d'une famille
une famille apparaît tu as des projets à
part d'être retourné paysans parce que
tes grands parents étaient paysans
j'ai été élevé par mail entre temps
envie de faire ça
quand on est encore plus loin que la
référence j'ai presque envie de re
devenir mon grand père
[Musique]
le futur m'intéresse pas vous
bizarre comme
[Musique]
si tu étais un défaut tu serais quoi
j'étais un défaut ouais l'envi qu'ils
ont envie d'aller assouvi un peu ton
envie là ça va non pas encore je vais
très très star une injure ça je sais pas
et quel peuple
un cadavre d'injures six membres en un
jour c'est celle de nietzsche qui sait
donner à l'autre la honte de soi c'est
la pire chose si tu le fais des fois
quand tu servait à saint tropez
telelangue de toi tu sais ça pour ça que
tu leur emploi et barclays et nettoyer
ses chemises tachées à la mousse au
chocolat ses terres et puis je compense
la prime filet 17 ans c'était une
infirmité
j'étais une infirmité autres incapable
d'aimer ça sur un assassin si j'étais un
ss peut-être landru parce qu'il aimait
vraiment les femmes et une guerre cgt
une guerre les guerres 17 daguerre les
sexes et
se passe bien quand même
c'est toujours avec cette fille qui
s'appelle marie quitte équilibre ouais
tu vas rester longtemps avec m mais
petit à petit j'ai trouvé ton chez toi
tu as trouvé ton perdu la trouvais mari
ça va s'arranger si tu étais une arme le
double tranchant auvergnats ouais si
jean-louis murat au cinéma le chanteur à
succès nous fait son premier n'avait
plus tomates et patata blind test hil
castagne monsieur campagne jean louis
murat bonsoir alors qu'elle a longtemps
été star d'une petite troupe de happy
few et puis tu as complètement éclatée
avec xian automne l'année dernière on a
vendu combien je dois être 60000 c'est
bien c'est dit une fois on est vraiment
soi même que dans le silence en auvergne
tranquille ça c'est une valeur des gens
de la campagne valeurs paysannes de
l'heure
de la campagne et moi je me sens assez
bien là dedans ça ne m'empêche pas
d'être une pipelette quand elle veut
mais je préférerais souvent me taire
souvent je regrette ce que j'ai dit oh
louvain ainsi pascal oui entre autres
c'est pialat ouais c'est bresson oui pas
mal oui c'est à force de dans les
interviews france 2
je dis toujours que je viens de
l'auvergne pour les parisiens c'est
toujours d'un désert culturel j'en sais
quoi oui c'est pour ça que j'étais
j'essaie toujours un peu d'encre et
l'auvergne dans des choses très très
forte c'est un peu une force tellurique
de l'auvergne avec certains écrivains on
retrouve toujours la même rigueur 1
coupe des jansénistes ou deux mois je me
sens bien maintenant tu as toujours
cette image comme ça à peu la pelouse
peu triste serghini où c'est ta vraie
nature
non c'est mon faux c'est ma vraie nature
parfois c'est ma nature
quand je suis à paris d'ailleurs quand
je suis comme je suis à paris quand je
vais en promo c'est vrai qu'il ya tout
le temps et j'ai pris l'avion il ya
trois quatre heures et je suis encore et
encore la moitié de moi même qui à
clermont ferrand ce que je suis un peu
un peu absent dans la présence quand
même alors les gens m'accusent de miles
ou constate on constate tout ça mais je
suis peut être je vais demander c'est un
gimmick non ou si c'était les migraines
chroniques la vega nine
ouais c'est ça ces puces est aujourd'hui
en plein de migraine fait ça et donc
tout prendre des trucs et ce à trois ans
comme ça ouais c'est la cousine qui sait
la comece web et je suis sûr qu'on est
conscient quoi parce qu'une fois tu as
dit je dois passer pour un pauvre petit
plus que c'est quand même bien que tu le
sais qu'on va
non mais c'est je pense que j'ai intégré
c'est dans un charme de mecs poussée
très bien nous les mecs qu'il faut alors
qu'est ce qui va sortir en disque là
dans les semaines qui viennent 45 tours
là il ya le prochain 45 et garder près
de moi qui sort dans quelques jours je
continue la promo sur l'album you rend
il y aura un crochet en 45 tours plus
tard au printemps peu et sinon je me
prépare le prochain à devoir devenu
havrais l'affairé artiste je l'étais
temps il y aura bonsoir bonsoir
alors avant de passer à des questions
plus personnelles je veux être demandée
sur ton avis tu crois qu'il existe une
association pour aider les gens à
décrocher du minitel rose ces deux là
font que c'est de l'intox
non je pense que c'est de l'info est ton
nouvel album s'appelle le col de la
croix morand et les gens ils voient chez
toi tu es des choses que lui mais
peut-être on a parlé de col de l'utérus
c'est moi qui ai parlé de colle de ligue
c'est vraiment un cas bien précis
d'ailleurs pour le l'anglais avec qui
j'ai travaillé sur le sur le clip pour
lui préciser quelle était l'idée caché
qu'il y avait derrière le col de la
croix mans je vais simplement rayé un
message en lui disant col de l'utérus
ça lui a été très utile le choix alors
tu as la considération des spécialistes
la considération du grand public mais tu
attends quand même un retour de bâton
comme tu dis pourquoi tu vas parler de
jeter comme un kleenex tu dis non je
pense que le succès ou le relatif succès
ça amène une rapport pornographiques et
que les médias dont deux en force d'être
pris tous azimuts et volontairement
arrive un moment où on se fait jeter on
peut pas être impunément la femme à tout
le monde même pas un peu tapis toyer sur
ton sort quand même c'est ma spécialité
mais ouais chacun acheter ça très bien
chacun la sienne
tu prends toujours autant de copies
toujours autant qui vit à la campagne en
auvergne
est-ce que tu soutiens les jacqueries de
paysans qui est un peu partout en france
en ce moment bien sûr je suis à fond
pour tout à fait tout en conseillant le
danger d'un ultra régionalisme un
nationalisme de lancer un peu l'échec
des socialistes d'ailleurs devoir
laisser là la campagne en jachère repris
au figuré ce qui fait que l'extrême
droite récupère habilement
on est que le message la terre c'est le
pen passe très très bien avec l'emploi
n'y est pas derrière tu dis que tu as
peur d'être attirés par les par les
valeurs de la terre par les dix mêmes
les valeurs de l'occupation bien sûr ça
te menace bien sûr non mais c'est un
danger pour tout le monde ça s'est passé
comment avec mylène farmer très bien
très bien aux agréables jeunes filles 1
et pour le partage des droits ça s'est
passé comment après dans la difficulté
mais c'était assez normal ray fait 55
ans annoncée elle a écrit la chanson
vraiment content du nouvel album de
robert wyatt
ouais t'as plus bas on et moi y est on
est moyen évident ce que je trouve un
peu ridicule c'est que c'est pas son
meilleur album que le précédent était
bien supérieur il ya un engouement
hypocrite de la presse sur wyatt sur un
point faisait album un album pour
allianz africa nous on aime le calme
merci à lyon ça fait une paye pense que
les maintenant oui d'une dizaine
d'années ouais tu viens comme nous
ricker moi je sais lire les artistes
jeunes au classement puisque les
artistes comme enfin ce que les enfants
des enfants les artistes j'étais vidé
buts et carey a vu débuter moi aussi je
t'ai vu débuter la première fois quand
on s'est vus ben vous viviez au dessus
de clermont ferrand et vous disiez quand
on vous parlait de clermont ferrand si
une ville car aucun charme le seul
charme c'est que c'est chez moi je vais
bien cette façon
reste à cause de murales coeur ouais
vous connaissez avant vous êtes de
murat-le-quaire moi j'ai des amis aux
dernières avancées des amis un vernis
avant on dirait quoi
avant de chanter avant de faire des
disques vous avez été disquaires été
barman et quand on s'est rencontrés on
m'avait raconté une histoire
je m'en souviens c'est que vous me
disiez que travailler comme barman à
saint tropez et que yahvé barclays qui
vous est
l'avc chemise avec sa tâche de mousse au
chocolat comme ça et après vous file edi
sac parce que vous aviez nettoyer sa
chemise
elle faisait même départ tous dans les
restos ont nettoyé auger a mais c'était
terrible c'est l'hymne national
quand je vais demander à la pire la pire
injure pour vous c'était voilà répandu
s'étaient donnés à l'autre la honte de
soi une phrase de nietzsche d'ailleurs
et là vous avez vous admirons de vous
barclays à ce moment là bah oui avec le
g en train de nettoyer ça a pris sa
fille l'inde a mis l'incroyable murat
mois mais beaucoup surpris parce qu'elle
ira il un truc formidable c'est qu'au
lieu de tirer sur les ambulances
ils tirent sur les vaches sacrées est ce
qui est quand même beaucoup plus
compliqué surtout beaucoup plus
courageux
on avait fait un blind test il y avait
brel et vous aviez répondu je trouve ça
dégoûtant fin il ya des choses qu'on
peut pas dire un peu de retenue quand
même oui brel c'est toujours une chance
non c'était sur le sous le coup de
l'émotion de nom mais j'ai jamais ça
jamais été ma tasse de thé
renault non plus remarqué parce que ma
et 10 pour le réalisme d'un journal
télévisé bas renaud gély ça c'est pas
mal c'est bien là mais c'est que dix ans
après on le répète
enfin je le répète on sait que c'est
bien mais dix ans après bizarre je vais
pas vous changer en même temps parce que
sur web city faisait déclaré par exemple
la chanson française trimballe des
dinosaures omniprésent mais c'est pas
pour ça qu'ils sont bons comme tous les
présentateurs télé de façon elles sont
indéboulonnables
ça se passe sur ce sont les
fonctionnaires cabrel ou goldman on n'y
échappe pas penser que cabrel ou que le
major je pense qu'on a une maison
phagocyter le marché de record en france
ouais dans les présentateurs télé ou les
chanteurs zeid urs 50 voiliers ponant
nouvellement c'est vrai tu prends les
dans les années 60 c'était déjà lui même
chose les années 70 au 6 mai 86 90 et
2010 on va se taper encore johnny et les
goldman cabrel et faute à deux titres
francophones ont alors radio vous en
pensez quoi
moi je passe à la radio van khê les
quotas et après j'ai giclé depuis que
les quotas il passe trois fois plus
hallyday goldmann et ils passent plus
des gars comme toi même passé passe en
radio
je pense pas du tout ouais ça vous
empêche pas de vendre des albums quand
même non non vous en prenez aux guignols
aussi mais je m'en prends à ce que
j'avais pu sélectionner au milieu j'ai
donné 150 interviews
évidemment vous sortez une dizaine de
phrases et vous pouvez facilement les
gens l'empruntent
non mais ça en prend nos guignols c'est
courageux attendez quoi vous si vous ai
dit quoi
ce qui m'intéresse et si vous attaquez
aux guignols parce que vous les comparez
à l'action française quand même c'est
violent oui je trouve que c'est que
c'est une élite arrogante qui s'est très
très bien se moquer des petites gens ce
fait qui m'énerve jour de foot vous avez
dit les joueurs de l'équipe de france
sont vautrés dans le monde médiatique
comme des pourceaux suite à la coupe du
monde
non mais quand tu aime le sport ou le ou
à suivre la coupe du monde d'un seul
coup ça on a affaire en affaires à
ulysse à pénélope
je ne sais quoi c'est vrai qu'après
quand on les voit vendredi à vendre des
conneries je trouvais que ça manquait de
sa banque et de classe quoi je pense que
les sportifs aux nuits avec les jambes
médias ils ont une sorte de rôle
éducatif un peu et qu'ils doivent savoir
se tenir de ce qu'ils servent
essentiellement d'exemple ils sont
beaucoup plus exemplaire que que les
cinq que les curés que les intellectuels
mal la robe couleur prof
on a d'ailleurs un peu les mettre devant
leurs responsabilités
vous avez bien aussi jean louis murat
c'est que vous défendez les gens qui
sont attaqués vous attaquez les guignols
en les comparant l'action française mais
vous dites que virenque par exemple ceux
qui lui ont fait ce qu'ils lui ont fait
devraient tomber sous le coup de la loi
sont des ordures vous dites oui je pense
que la façon de traiter irak mais je
trouve que c'est un peu moi j'ai été
élevé comme ça les mecs qui traite à 1
quand on traite un petit gars comme ça
c'est une ordure et normalement la loi
de refaire son boulot pour défendre les
publics c'est que dans le cyclisme tout
le monde se charge simplement lui aussi
bien sûr mais il n'a pas les mots pour
expliquer qu'il se charge c'est ça vous
fait
s'il n'a pas le dis ça mais essentielle
ment ben oui mais l'angle des attaques
survient un accès cesson
sans vocabulaire et je trouve ça
dégueulasse on se moque de lui parce
qu'il sait pas parler je trouve ça moi
je suis dans un milieu où les gens moi
mes grands parents parler
essentiellement patois et quand il
parlait en français n'était pas très
habile
je trouve ça bien de se moquer des gens
qui savent pas s'exprimer
et ouais t'es pas la seule
elle va raconter des trucs quand on sait
comment ça c'est passé juste qui dit
entièrement d'accord
j'ai souvent été d'accord avec lui là
vous avez l'air quand même mieux dans
votre peau qu'à dix ans tu seras vous
aussi ses premiers 45 tours de murat
s'appelait suicidez vous le peuple est
mort je vais pas retrouvé derrière jules
et le violet voudrait base ing patrice
coppee aujourd'hui vous êtes plutôt fêté
par les médias vous êtes plutôt bien
bien reconnu chez vous fait un disque à
libération qu'on fait deux pages savane
on teste un as a service y est c'est
officiel c'est gentil ça non pourquoi de
dire que libération en fait deux pages
une en or dans votre bouche c'est
pourquoi au contraire moi un pas du tout
titouan jean-louis là-dessus c'est super
c'est adulé aujourd'hui n'en parle pas
mais à part la critique parce que j'ai
deux pages dans libération la retrouver
dans les inrocks et dans des tas de
journaux qui font l'opinion vous êtes
vous disent tout tout s'explique
on se demandait tous ça c'est le vrai
dieu me parfume non le bois un coin bar
vite j'en ai marre de la tristesse je
préfère la sérénité ses forces et pas
bouddhisme est influencé par la
philosophie bouddhiste où ça moi vous
êtes mire et gymnastique
ouais ça descend
[Applaudissements]
dès que j'ai pu me créer très consensuel
en plus maintenant fait des chansons
contre le front national les grossesses
et les [ __ ] serrer les fesses voilà les
gonzesses et les [ __ ] mais gré à gré
c'est pourquoi j'ai fait cette chanson
pour aller chanter à vitrolles il
fallait avoir la chanson je n'avais pas
la chance trouvé d'accord je suis une
chanson jazz y en a une aussi tout le
monde il est beau sauf jean marie le pen
vous savez qu'on a c'est l'épée des
papes a attendu sa cette espèce de on
peut toujours dire ça mais autant le
faire ouais c'est fait c'est fait on
peut toujours un peu de joueurs de
mauvais esprit pour dire que ça un peu
attendu bien que les gens quel mauvais
esprit et dans un monde où tout le monde
non croyez pas this is ici non mais
c'est vous qui posez des questions
difficiles à définir c'est scarlett
o'hara satisfaite et jamais d'orgasme
c'est ce que vous avez dit non je sais
pas comment se fait-il c'est vous et
autant frapper la question parce que
vous avez de vous avez quand même une
séduction qui est assez trouble alors
j'ai trouvé scarlett o'hara fait déjà
mais c'est excitant que vous ayez sorti
cette phrase assez excitant je suis là
c'est bien on finit bien c'est qu'en
maintenant je suis d'accord qu'il
s'appelle hardy c'est très excitant
à oui qu'est-ce qui vous fascine dans
l'univers féminin justement vous qu'être
fasciné par l'univers féminin et fille
qui auront this un peu comme ça mais qui
résiste encore leur part d'organes l on
était là avant moi c'est fait deux mois
qu'on a c'est vrai il ya des trucs là ce
soir tu respectes un sentiment nouveau
c'est jean louis murat
hahaha
à
là
alors jean louis vous arrivez tout de
suite on est à la fiche 69 donc on est à
la question de la fiche 69
vous savez que les rôles sont inversés
et c'est vous jean-louis qu'ils allaient
me poser une question
tu connais les chefs d'arrondissement du
69 livres au nom de la culture à la télé
ou encore moi je suis un des plus
cultivés imaginez bien dire vous êtes
une sorte de moujik de la musique d'une
certaine façon en pole man c'est pas mal
comme formule magique de la musique
ensemble en que c'est un paysan russe
toi ça vous gêne de faire la promo à la
télé non j'aime beaucoup ça
[Musique]
ce que j'ai lu des propos de vous pas
désobligeant pour moi mais très très
très désobligeant pour mais bon mes
confrères nous étions de parfaire leurs
émissions si vous n'avez pas envie de
faire de promo à la télé si vous allez
pas en faire parce que j'avais le choix
c'était vous fogiel
ouais je vous ai choisis vous c'est
gentil merci aux besoins massifs les
saloperies sur fogiel j'aurais pu dire
sur vous aussi oui c'est vrai soyez
fusil et a tiré au sort voilà c'est avec
votre copain là il n'y est pas allé de
main morte avec fogiel a way lubango pas
stéphane avec vous ives aussi alors moi
ce que j'ai lu c'est votre copain mais
manqueront pas stéphane sûr oui bon on
va d'abord des copains cas stéphane
c'est encore mieux on va voir votre
copain l'a donc il dit en parlant de
marc olivier fogiel il se trémousse
tellement on dirait qu'il a collé un
gode sur sa chaise
c'est nul ça sympa non là vous serez
plus obligé d'y aller chez fogiel vous
savez ça maintenant tu ici m'a invité
choix je vais y aller
ah bon mais il faut par contre il faut
que je vous disais c'est signer avec les
blacks de mon copain c'est d'accord mais
vous épargner pas le métier non plus en
parlant du patron d'universal pascal
[ __ ]
c'est à dire marquer ses membres vous
êtes le seul en fait ce qui est génial
c'est le seul qui dit des trucs au fait
que c'est drôle quoi
bah ouais ça que tu lance donc pascal
[ __ ] le patron d'universal vous avez
dit quel loupé deux charcutiers il a
normalisé gala devrait dé couper des
têtes de veau sauce est génial
en revanche la donne et vous dites pas
que des vaches comme dit aussi des trucs
très vrai vous avez dit c'est vrai que
la chanson française ressemble de plus
en plus à la variété internationale de
moins en moins d'auteur compositeur
interprète est de plus en plus
d'interprètes dans les maisons de
disques font absolument ce qu'elles
veulent ça c'est vrai c'est bientôt vous
trouvez ça pertinents ouais je vous cela
pertinent d'autant plus que vous e mail
d'autant plus que vous ajoutez t juillet
prenez une photo tient en vie
je trouve ça pertinent d'autant plus que
vous ajoutez que ce sont tous des
chanteurs de balle je trouve ça assez
bien je dis c'est que finalement ce qui
est typique de cette nouvelle race de
chanteur ce sont les chanteurs québécois
parce qu'ils sont trop fort est parce
que je pense que la langue française
c'est une langue de c'est une langue de
la de l'intimité et de la passion et du
plaisir c'est non mais plutôt une langue
chuchoter c'est vrai que c'est dire que
oui c'est vrai que les gens qui parlent
fort ont du mal à penser finement et je
prépare le chanteur c'est un peu par
contre si tu veux parler un tout petit
peu plus fort parce qu'un pas
au caire les raismois le plexus tout ce
qui s'appelle baby karni birds sur le
sur le loft vous n'avez pas aimé love
story vous pas tellement que j'ai pas
aimé ça c'est comment la presse et
comment les gens se sont frais là dedans
est devenu une sorte de sport national
de commenter cette chose assez médiocre
c'était un peu humiliant pour tout le
monde mais c'est vrai que tout le monde
s'engage et là dedans il ya un type très
connue au monde s'appelle daniel
schneidermann qui donne des leçons de
morale à tout le monde toutes les
semaines on y vient il a écrit le
spectacle en parlant du loft
le spectacle de télévision le plus neuf
le plus créatif et le plus intéressant
programmer ces dernières années sur les
écrans français
face à ces derniers temps le monde en
conneries ses fins ouais ouais
oui j'ai remarqué c'est le même meuwly
m'bolhi sur son selon 70 tours non une
légère à lui une nouvelle volonté vivre
[Musique]
vous l'avez réservé celui-là alors eh
ben oui alors oui vous avez d'autres
fiches l'avouer un paquet fille j'en ai
plein pour le oui non en fait je vais
vous dire pourquoi j'ai pris un petit
show puisque vous êtes un titre quand
même assez paradoxale d'un côté vous
êtes énervé par ces chanteurs qu'on
lance comme des savonnettes là vous
dites moi je bosse pendant des heures
avec mon piano ma guitare et tout moi je
suis un vrai quoi je travaille je me
donne du mal et en fait quand on voit
comment vous avez enregistré ce disque
que vous promotionner aujourd'hui le
moujik et sa femme
vous dites que vous l'avez enregistré en
douze heures ouais comme dylan deux
heures par jour
on a vu des mecs maîtres de trois ans
d'en faire un album
l'ébranlement font pas de deux dragons
faire un homme stills énimie s'emparant
tuer laurent voulzy la mi-novembre faire
son album c'est du marketing au reste du
torrent ou faisais du foot à la piscine
le nom jeune âge et des pétards non je
mets les musiciens
j'ai la mémoire qui flanche
c'est fini ce pas vous êtes bonnes
critiques c'est essentiel d'être content
non comme d'habitude libération les
inrocks
comment sa libération au maroc mais
malheureux il ya des centaines de médias
il ya un pack 2 c'est vous qui vous
ouvre ses vouliez vous voulez vous
disais que c'est de manier le bonus de
grainger lui elle aussi avaliser l ai
regardé des photos non non je lis j'ai
vu qu' il y avait toutes les femmes 18
paires guerre des clips toutes les
femmes de l disent du bien de vous vous
êtes très très très aimé des femmes
katherine pancol pascale clark que
christine angot car denis verdini ma
copine vous aimez les femmes elles vous
le rendent bien
quel gardien parce que vous l'aimez sauf
qu'il a une voix envoûtante j'aime
beaucoup aussi les chiens comme les
fumées mais je les aime beaucoup
non mais c'est vrai vous dit quand je
tombe amoureux c'est une opportunité
pour changer chaque fille ne chamboulent
je prends ces gestes je change votre
toilette
si elle se lève plus tard je me cale sur
son rythme si elle s'habille en grenat
je vais m'acheter des trucs grenat se
clôt fille c'est ça l'amour c'est
l'amour c'est un vrai une forme de
labour est pas en forme qui moi je vais
très bien ça va comme d'habitude elles
sont pas terribles ces questions c'est à
des questionnements le jour au mieux
fait d'aller chez fogiel
c'est quand un prochain album c'est
quand dans deux jours vous êtes adulé
par la critique c'est vrai et par le
public
ouais nan mais les ventes ne suivent pas
comment ça se fait je vend 100 milles à
chaque fois ça me va très bien
ça suffit enfin dès que tu penses de
trois albums en même temps tu paies
300000 commence à ce que vous soyez pas
un chanteur populaire ce qui est cher et
rare ouais vous passer en radio man
entassons et sont obligés de passer des
chansons françaises à la radio n'en fait
pas fait débat
j'ai eu un petit budget pour faire ce
disque là non c'est de la blague ça j'ai
un budget énorme
normal parce que votre maison de disques
il paraît qu'ils vous donneront deux
fois - ci marche pas vous dise
vas-y amuse-toi faire une demie
d'audience qui lorsqu'on fait c'est un
peu le parent pauvre dans votre maison
de disques n'ont pas du tout non
je suis le chouchou mais par exemple
vous fait la promo ouais vous êtes dans
un très bel hôtel pour recevoir les
journalistes et après vous allez dormir
dans un hôtel moins bien c'est vrai bah
oui c'est normal
pourquoi tu fais pas l'un vers 9h10 lui
donne pas un bel hôtel n'était jour je
comprends pas non mais je sais pas enfin
je peux à peine de dépenser des fortunes
dans des chambres d'hôtel un lycéen lee
c'est vrai que voulez vous installer
dans le sud par exemple question idiote
comme ça mais qui peut vous donner
l'occasion de vous exprimer oui oui je
ne suis pas encore truction jeudi
pensais je voulais quitter l'auvergne
voit une question non je sais pas encore
on ne pense pas
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu veux jouer ou non
maintenant je vais bien je veux jouer
non mais excusez moi j'étais un mauvais
client j'étais pas du tout alors est ce
que jean louis murat vous est pris pour
une interview jugement dernier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean louis murat ben c'est le jugement
dernier
mais j'en ai eu ras vous pensé à la mort
une demi-heure par jour
ah bon donc vous êtes prêts pour
l'interview jugement dernier
jean louis murat quand tu étais petit as
tu essayé de regarder sous le bureau de
ta maîtresse jamais il était plein as-tu
enfermer des élèves de sexe féminin dans
les cabinets jamais il est en plein air
jean louis murat tu jouer au docteur
avec tes copains jamais il n'y était
jamais malade
très bien merci jean louis murat avec ce
professeur d'anglais qui t'a fait lire
coridon es tu sûr qu'il ne sais vraiment
rien passé sexuellement tu es bien bien
surprenant jean louis murat
as-tu utiliser ta notoriété pour obtenir
des avantages particuliers
des fois les bonnes places pour les
autres ça absorbe tue encore des
substances illicites
jamais jamais mais tu as su ou pas
justement c'est bien correct on tond pu
relier à thouars un éventuel m'est
étranger est il arrivé d'avoir envie de
la femme d'un autre j'aime et j'ai des
principes est il arrivé de trompeta
femmes
jamais gêné principe est il arrivé de
trompeta maîtresse
c'est jamais une maîtresse jean louis
murat
as tu ne serait ce qu'une fois emmerder
le monde par plaisir jamais
je pense que même dieu tu vas arriver à
le faire chier au jugement dernier
j'espère faire des photos pour reporter
sans frontières alors cet appareil photo
tu fais des photos ouais tu les fais pas
développer ouais et au mois de juin
s'est vendu aux enchères au profit de
reporter sans frontières certaines
photos de stars on le donne qu'à des
stars c'est une bonne idée d'afrique du
c'était mieux passer parce qu'avais
linda hardy future linda hardy sur l
rosie c'est ici à saint cyr à l'aide de
petits seins emplois qu'elle arrêtait
pas de montrer
[Musique]